[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 actualité idées de sorties
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines voici le sommaire de ce 18
février
et jusqu'à dimanche c'est la cinquième
édition de sport féminin toujours pour
plus de visibilité dans les médias on en
parle de sport féminin justement avec
mon invitée et qui est responsable de la
commission sport féminin au comité
départemental olympique et sportif 60,18
marion hébrard alors que les jo de pékin
s'achève ce week-end nous vous emmenons
pratiquer les sports d'hiver à la
verrière la ville et l'ufolep 78 propose
de découvrir les disciplines jusqu'au 4
mars curling hockey ou encore biathlon
et puis comme tous les vendredis nos
idées de sorties dans les yvelines pour
le week-end mais aussi pour les vacances
d'hiver qui débute ce soit et c'est bien
sûr avec mon acolyte du vendredi bixente
malien santisteva bonjour bixente je
gagnerai non ça va en cette fin de
semaine très bien et vous comment ça se
passe les vacances qui arrivent écoutez
on n'a pas la chance on ne fait pas
partie de ces trois cent mille élèves
chanceux qui a seront en vacances ce
soir mais on est tout de même heureux de
présenter le programme de ce qui va se
passer dans les vacances c'est au menu
aujourd'hui de vos idées de sorties
justement voilà une grande partie de la
programmation du jour du menu du jour
sera autour de ses vacances scolaires
qui arrive et c'est à suivre bien sûr
tout à l'heure dans le 7-8 week-end
nj - 8 avant le salon de l'agriculture
qui va faire son grand retour à paris
porte de versailles après deux ans
d'absence avant l'événement un camion
interactif et le tour de france pour
sensibiliser les jeunes aux métiers et
la de la filière et de l'alimentation et
qui représente lui-même 3,4 millions
d'emplois dans l'hexagone laventure du
vivant fait étape en ce moment à
versailles et c'est jusqu'à samedi le
reportage justement de bixente magnin
sortie steban en face du château de
versailles aux grandes écuries royales
un camion orange en sont fort simulateur
casque de réalité virtuelle et écrans
interactifs
on est venus en bus et maintenant on va
découvrir les métiers etc au vrai j'ai
appris plein de trucs c'est intéressant
c'est pour faire vivre l'expérience donc
dans les caisses que 3d on va voir par
exemple des métiers comme élagueurs pour
vraiment faire vivre le métier de
l'intérieur et une expérience immersive
et on a réussi
un test pour faire de la conduite
d'engins agricoles donc voilà c'est
vraiment immersif des outils pour
renseigner les jeunes aux métiers du
vivant mais pas seulement tout est
aujourd'hui
très très informatisée et il ya beaucoup
d'exploitants qui gèrent leur
exploitation de presque dans le bureau
et avec des écrans pour gérer la traite
des vaches
l'alimentation externe donc donc c'est
ça qui intéresse aussi les jeunes et et
contrôlant ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est vraiment très très technologique à
des drones il ya toutes ces choses là
qui sont aujourd'hui nous intéresse
énormément les jeunes les classes de
collèges et lycées sont divisés en deux
groupes l'un se focalise sur la pratique
l'autre échanges sur les métiers de
l'enseignement agricole qui assure
aujourd'hui 90 % d'insertion
professionnelle typiquement il ya des
métiers qu'on ne pense pas à trouver
dans les établissements agricoles ça va
être le service à la personne
les filières de la vente ça c'est des
métiers qui sont alors connu par
ailleurs mais qu'on trouve pas il faut
qu'on pense pas trouver là et après il
ya des métiers qui sont moins connus
tout ce qui va être viticulture par
exemple arboriculture un petit peu des
sections de la production mais
spécifique après son escale dans la cité
royale le camion mise en place par le
ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation se rendra à chartres puis
sera stationné à paris porte de
versailles
pendant les dix jours du salon
international de l'agriculture
la joie des élèves du lycée hoche de
versailles le lycée s'est adjugé le
derby contre ginette 51 à 47 c'était ce
jeudi au centre sportif mont boron à
versailles dans une ambiance est digne
des campus américains depuis 2004 un
match de basket oppose les lycée
sainte-geneviève dit ginette et auch un
duel imaginé par un professeur de ps
françois allaman pour l'anecdote c'est
seulement la deuxième victoire de auchan
c'est édition nous reviendrons largement
sur ce rendez vous dans notre émission
sept sports ce lundi sur tv 78
toute cette semaine le ministère des
sports et le monde sportif et l'art
comme sont mobilisés pour le sport
féminin sport féminin toujours se
déroule jusqu'à dimanche pour plus de
médiatisation des compétitions féminines
et aussi favoriser plus d'égalité plus
de pratique pour les femmes le hashtag
également plus de sport au féminin a été
lancée pour en faire la promotion sur
les réseaux sociaux et on en parle avec
mon vite et c'est marion evrard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes responsable de la
commission sport féminin au coût de 2 78
alors le dos c'est le comité
départemental olympique et sportif des
yvelines selon vous quel est l'intérêt
de cette opération et pourquoi est-elle
primordial cette opération sport au
féminin et bien c'est très important
parce qu'effectivement il est très
important de montrer des sportives en
action sur les met dans tous les médias
parce que il n'y en a pas assez et de
montrer des sportifs de haut niveau
c'est quelque chose aussi qui peuvent
faire venir qui peuvent faire adhérer
des femmes et vais revenir des femmes
aux sports donc c'est important que l'on
montre que les femmes ont toute leur
place dans le sport est une très très
grande place mais tu dynamique on
imagine encore plus importante en vue
des jeux olympiques de 2024 et une tante
qui ont déroulé sur le territoire
français et aussi sur les yvelines les
yvelines voilà avec terre de jeux et b
nommément deux villes qui sont
actuellement labellisé terre de jeu pour
aussi bien faire les les entraînements
les recevoir les athlètes et puis faire
des activités que les communes fassent
des activités en vue des jo de 2022
sitôt leur qui coule c'est un sur le
territoire des yvelines alors
aujourd'hui si on regarde les chiffres
franciliens les femmes représentent 38%
de la pratique sportive dans les
quartiers prioritaires on est encore
plus loin de cette parité puisque le
chiffre descend à 25%
quelle est la situation dans les
yvelines est ce que la tendance est
similaire la tendance est un peu plus
basse dans les yvelines parce que
en france tout dépend des sports en fait
il ya des sports qui ramène les love qui
prennent les femmes prennent énormément
de parler de l'équitation
pratiquement une majorité enfin plus qu
une majorité presque unanimité de femmes
les la gymnastique également tout les
sports de danses bien sûr
par contre quand on parle de rugby ou du
foot là c'est plus du tout la même chose
dans les yvelines c'est plutôt 28% nous
on fait au niveau du coeur sont faits
dès décidé d pourcentage par rapport à
nos adhérents on a une quarantaine de
fédérale 2 comités départementaux
adhérents et on peut constater à peu
près 28% de femmes parmi ces les clubs
de ces comités tu % de pratiquants dans
les élites alors ça c'est pour les
pratiquants du côté du monde dirigeant
on sait qu'au niveau national il ya
beaucoup de progrès à faire sur la place
des femmes justement dans des postes de
dirigeants est ce que dans les yvelines
sa progrès là aussi là aussi ça
progresse parce que bah déjà on cherche
on a toujours besoin de bénévoles et de
10,2 dirigeants pour monter des
associations pour les faire vivre et les
femmes ils viennent parce qu'elles ont
elles ont ressenti la nécessité
elles viennent un peu plus tard quand
elles n'ont plus d'activité
professionnelle ou plus d'enfants abbas
occuper un peu plus de temps à consacrer
aux associations hélas elle rentre
volontiers dans l'est dans les postes de
dirigeant vous diriez sur les dernières
années il ya une amélioration du point
de vue des dirigeants aussi sur les
pratiquants il ya une amélioration alors
les comités départementaux des
différentes disciplines et ce qu'ils
sont justement investi vous avez cette
impression là sur sur cette thématique
du sport féminin alors c'est oui ça
dépend
je crois que c'est surtout les clubs qui
sont investis les comités départementaux
ils sont enfin moi je vois plus le mien
qui est du tir à l'arc bon c'est un
sport où yahoo soit pas tout à fait
autant de femmes que d'hommes il ya
beaucoup de femmes et mais dans les
comités départementaux il je crois
qu'ils ont plus de choses à gérer
d'autres choses à gérer enfin ils
s'organisent organisent des
manifestations pour promouvoir le sport
pour les femmes mais je crois qu'ils
laissent plus l'initiative aux clubs qui
me font des démarches spécifiques
en aménageant les horaires en faisant
des rencontres et des séances
spécifiques avec les mamans avec leurs
enfants pour que les mamans partie
pratiquer le même sport que l'enfant et
ça les fait venir et en même temps ils
ont leurs enfants avec eux donc c'était
c'est très important donc si les clubs
créés des démarches et des activités
comme ça pour faire venir pour faire
venir les femmes plus haut niveau des
déclins des bleus qui a les dynamiques
qui souhait qui se crée pour le 2,78
justement quel est le rôle du comité
départemental olympique sportif
justement dans la promotion de ce sport
fait nord nous organisons deux cours de
concours essentiellement deux concours
un concours qui a lieu tous les ans qui
s'appelle aux yvelines
opération pour un sport égalitaire qui
est en partenariat avec le service
départemental de la jeunesse de
l'engagement et des sports du 78 et
actif qui met en avant sa qui récompense
des structures sportives
association bien sûr associations
sportives et associations scolaires qui
font des idées montrent des actions pour
promouvoir le sport les le sport des
femmes des saisons que je vienne pour
les encourager et également tout ce qui
est prévention prévention de toutes les
incivilités de toutes les les
comment les atteintes
des violences toutes les violences
sexuelles ou autres gels et les
inégalités
tous les discriminations qui peut y
avoir au niveau du sport donc ça c'est
pour le premier concours et le deuxième
le deuxième c'est marraine de filles
alors là s'est dirigé vers des personnes
des individualités qui dans un club vont
avoir réalisé des actions soit pour
augmenter le nombre de femmes dans leur
club soit pour développer une action
particulièrement en vue des femmes soit
pour me mettre en place un entraînement
ou une encadrement spécifique féminin
donc ça ça fait partie des actions du
gloss en 78 puis va essayer de
l'influencer tous les comités
départementaux et les clubs à faire
quelque chose pour pour le sport au
féminin
marion hébrard d'être venu en plateau
pour parler de parler de cette
thématique je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable de la commission sport
féminin au 2,78 inquiet le comité
départemental olympique sportif et des
yvelines est je le rappelle un sport
féminin toujours cette opération se
déroule jusqu'à dimanche n'hésitez pas
d'ailleurs à utiliser le hashtag plus de
sport au féminin plus de sport au
féminin le hashtag pour faire la
promotion du sport féminin sur les
réseaux sociaux sport féminin toujours
cette opération était au coeur de
l'actualité de la semaine mais que s'est
il passé d'autres dans les yvelines ces
derniers jours mélanie poké vous résume
le tout en 78 secondes
[Musique]
elle a dû marcher de maurepas a connu
une nouvelle étape à trailer de 110
dévastateur de 2019 le site est au coeur
d'une concertation les mort patients ont
découvert le week-end dernier les plans
imaginés pour une reconstruction en 2024
un couple noir que nous juste parmi les
nations aurélien et julianne moore un
habitant de lui mais ont accueilli
pendant deux ans le jeune henry dauman
une cérémonie s'est tenue à levallois
perret les six agents du service sont
actuellement aux formations la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux va
bientôt être armés
le nouveau maire de mantes-la-jolie
devrait être connu au plus tard le 22
mai les dates pour la municipale
partielle sont connus premier tour le 15
mai quatre candidats se sont déclarés
dont raphaël cogner maire démissionnaire
en janvier la maison de l'europe des
yvelines a 20 ans et pour cette double
décennie la structure organisée un temps
des changes pensé et créé l'agriculture
de demain ce 16 février c'était le coup
d'envoi pour les startups sélectionnées
par hectare
le plus grand campus agricoles du monde
aux entreprises ont aussi développé une
yvelinoise décor et gabriela boda
directrice musicale de la maîtrise de
trappes a reçu les insignes de chevalier
de l'ordre national de la légion
d'honneur
[Musique]
et puis votre rubrique légal chez king
pour vérifier ce que disent les acteurs
de l'actualité c'est avec le collectif
des surligneurs raphaël mata duvignau
décrypte aujourd'hui une proposition du
député de la somme insoumis françois
ruffin et bloquer bloquer les dividendes
chez un géant de l'énergie
françois ruffin a demandé au
gouvernement de bloquer la distribution
des dividendes chez total energy après
l'annoncé d'un bénéfice de 16 milliards
de dollars pour l'année 2000 21 alors
soyons clairs cette proposition est
parfaitement contraire au droit de la
propriété privée protégée par la
constitution pour rappel les
actionnaires sont des investisseurs
financiers qui sont titulaires d'actions
achetées sur les marchés boursiers et
qui espère en retirer profit par la
distribution d'une part des bénéfices
réalisés durant l'année en contrepartie
ils prennent le risque de perdre leurs
investissements en contribuant aux
pertes en cas de mauvais résultat il
revient donc à l'assemblée générale des
actionnaires est à elle seule en toute
liberté et en toute indépendance de
décidé de distribuer ses dividendes d'y
renoncer ou d'en limiter la distribution
précisons également que le droit de haut
dividende est une des composantes de la
propriété privée donc les dividendes
auxquels les actionnaires ont droit sont
protégés par la constitution et par la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
qu'il y ait privation totale de ce droit
ou simplement limitations dans les
conditions de son exercice donc toi
aller dans le sens de françois ruffin le
gouvernement est juridiquement limitée
et ne peut pas prendre de mesures
contraignantes donc que faire
dans les entreprises où il est
actionnaire l'état pourrait à l'occasion
d'une assemblée générale voté contre la
distribution des dividendes mais cela ne
peut fonctionner que s'il parvient à
former une majorité autour de lui il
pourrait aussi décider que les
entreprises qui continueraient à verser
ses dividendes ce va être exclu des
mesures de soutien économique adopté en
mars 2020 pour modérer les conséquences
de la pandémie politiquement c'est assez
difficile il pourrait aussi proposer de
modifier la législation fiscale en
augmentant par exemple la fiscalité sur
les bénéfices possibles mais ce tombeau
ne doit pas avoir de caractère
rétroactif
dernière hypothèse qui ne serait sans
doute pas pour déplaire la france
soumise modifier la constitution en
restreignant le droit de propriété mais
alors on reviendrait sur l'un des
principaux acquis de la révolution
française ce qui serait à la fois
paradoxal est gênant
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
[Musique]
et c'est bien sûr bixente mayence anti
steban qui vous sert de guide chaque
semaine ce vendredi bixente on disait
tout à l'heure c'est le début des
vacances d'hiver et on va forcément
parler aujourd'hui alors que les jo de
pékin alors ça c'est une autre actualité
vont se clôturer aussi ce week-end on va
découvrir les sports d'hiver alors ce
qui est drôle c'est qu'on ne quitte pas
les yvelines où on peut découvrir ces
sports de montagne directement dans les
portables comme à la maison à jusqu'au 4
mars l'ufolep 78 organise son
wintherthour avec la ville de la
verrière l école régionale de premier
degré quelques jours pour découvrir les
sports d'hiver on enfile ses gants son
bonnet et sa petite écharpe grégory avec
mélanie poké et nicolas d'andry
les sports d'hiver ce n'est pas qu'à la
montagne la verrière une centaine de
jeunes découvrent plusieurs disciplines
sportives toutes liées à cette époque de
l'année j'aime bien pourquoi on s'amuse
comme mon pote on s'amuse tout s'est tu
sais trop bien je trouve que la
patinoire est assez amusant mais c'est
pas de la vraie glace le hockey j'ai
beaucoup adoré et le choeur lee hooker
jr va la cabine j'ai ouais voilà ça
passe encore à l'organisation du fola 78
fédération sportive multisports qui en
ligne patinage escalade ou encore ok
l'objectif faire découvrir des sports
originaux avec en ligne de mire paris
2024 on a souhaité rassembler sur un
site
qui s'y prêtait celui de la rpd de la
verrière un ensemble d'activités qui
sont en phase avec les jeux olympiques
de pékin sur lesquels on retrouvait à
peu près toutes les activités de
montagne qui s'adresse plus
particulièrement un public qui n'a
peut-être pas la chance de pouvoir en
profiter seuls 10% des français vont
tous qui chaque année 40 % ne sont même
jamais allé ça permet de découvrir des
sports ça permet de travailler la
cohésion des équipes ça permet pendant
les vacances avec le centre aéré de
s'aérer la tête et de se dépenser au
plus près de chez soi donc on a
effectivement un partenariat qui gagnant
gagnant autour des valeurs du sport il
est important de mutualiser les moyens
un petit peu pour pouvoir aussi faire
vivre je dirais les instants éducatif
que doivent avoir les enfants les
vacances apprenantes et plus on
s'associe ensemble et plus on développe
nos partenariats la ville s'est
rapproché essentiellement des centres de
loisirs structures de jeunesse et
certaines écoles le winter tour se
déroule jusqu'au 4 mars prochain
et c'est une activité parmi tant
d'autres affaires sont le rappelle je l'
ai dit plusieurs fois c'est le début ce
soir michel t'aider à vacances d'hiver
trois cent mille élèves yvelinois de la
maternelle au lycée qu'ils sont chanceux
et qui vont pouvoir profiter de ses
congés mais qui dit vacances dit
forcément activités à trouver si vous
vous demandez comment occuper vos
enfants nous avons avec nos plateaux
sénile chars qui n'est pas licite heures
mais qui va trouver quelques réponses
pour vous et oui il est parfois
difficile de trouver quoi faire pendant
les vacances scolaires surtout quand il
fait encore un petit peu froid dehors
comme maintenant mais je vous ai trouvé
de quoi remédier à ça alors d'abord je
vous conseille d'aller faire un tour du
côté des musées il propose de nombreuses
activités ou stages ludiques comme des
activités essentiellement manuelle de la
gravure de la peinture ou encore de la
confection d'objets par exemple vous
pouvez vous renseigner du côté du musée
maurice ravel à montfort l'amaury du
côté du musée maurice denis à saint
germain en laye ou encore le musée de la
ville à montigny le bretonneux le musée
du jouet à poissy propose également
plusieurs activités un grand panel
d'activités c'est emilie - qui va nous
en parler pendant les vacances sont
propose déjà des dimanche on un
spectacle du magicien il reste encore
quelques places disponibles
sinon on a nos habituels atelier alors
c'est des ateliers pour les 4 6 ans et
pour les 7 12 ans le dimanche 27 février
à 15h30 on a un spectacle de théâtre
d'ombrés qui a lieu dans la salle
d'atelier du musée du jouet qui
s'adresse aux enfants à partir de 6 ans
et c'est avec la compagnie coppélius le
mardi 1er mars à 14h30 on a un spectacle
on a un atelier sur le maquillage qui
est proposée par une maquilleuse
professionnelle qui va apprendre aux
enfants à se grimer en animaux avec le
mât sera surtout un maquillage des yeux
et enfin on propose le vendredi 4 mars à
10 heures là c'est un atelier sculpture
en clape là où les enfants vont pouvoir
s'initier pour construire des aliments
au cap la des tours eiffel
il ne faut pas perdre de temps parce que
beaucoup d'activités sont déjà quasiment
complète donc ça c'était pour les plus
petits mais qu'est ce que vous avez à
nous proposer aussi pour les collégiens
et lycéens alors tous les plus grands je
vous propose d'aller faire un tour du
côté de guyancourt il propose deux
structures donc on a le point jeunes
avec des activités pour les 11 15 ans ou
plutôt les collégiens et le phare
jeunesse pour les lycéens alors de ce
côté là les deux structures proposent un
vaste programme d'activités on a de la
magie du bowling des jeux vidéo de la
cuisine ou encore du sport il y en a
pour tous les goûts par exemple un stage
de hand ball sur trois jours qui se
termine sur une soirée avec un match plg
handball on a également des sorties
expositions à paris ou encore une sortie
à la piscine patinoire de chartres une
spécificité également cette année il
propose une formation bafa va proposer
une formation bafa le début de la
formation bafa non jeune et est la
spécificité de guyancourt c'est que ben
on va accompagner on prend en charge
cette formation ça va coûter 200 euros
aux jeunes pour une formation qui est de
l'ordre de 800 euros et donc on les fait
des formations on les accompagne du
groupe stage pratique puisqu'on leur
proposera un stage pratique dans nos
structures cet été pendant les vacances
d'été nous à structure d'accueil de
loisirs et l'objectif c'est que
puisqu'ils et puis savoir qui publie
cette baffe à ise en novembre et la
formation commencera la semaine
prochaine et se déroulera pendant huit
mois bien ça fait déjà beaucoup de
choses que vous nous proposez céline
mais on
ce qu'on peut faire une petite dernière
idée pour la route et oui encore un peu
plus si les incontournables animaux pour
amuser petits et grands comptes bien sûr
à la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
la maison des ancêtres à carrières sous
poissy ou bien la ferme de gally de
saint cyr outre les chèvres vaches
moutons et cochons qui plairont
évidemment aux enfants elle propose des
ateliers de fabrication du pain des
ateliers de barattage du beurre de
fabrication de nourrisseur un oiseau de
jus de pomme frais ou encore des
enquêtes et enfin pour finir petite
dernière activité pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas partir au jeu aux sports
d'hiver le centre commercial one nation
paris au kg est installé aux
clayes-sous-bois propose trois activités
une piste de luge de 18 mètres de
curling un parcours de hockey et toutes
ces animations sont gratuites tous les
jours de 14 heures à 18 heures alors
c'est beaucoup céline vous avez une
petite préférence vous irez où pendant
ce serait faire un pull juge
dans le courant du mois le psg handball
je crois qu'un petit match de handball
samedi rennes la cgt qui parle on
connaît ce côté bixente merci céline
pour toutes ces idées de sorties et vous
en avez d'autres bixente on part à
présent aux ballades doit se balader
exactement en fait les balades divers
plus précisément c'est le nom d'un mini
festival qui se déroule jusqu'au 26
février dans toute la vallée de seine en
tout huit spectacles vivants à
destination du jeune public se
produiront dans divers lieux culturels
des représentations complètement
différente entre théâtre musique danse
ou encore compte c'est l'association les
400 coups qui organise cet événement
nous avons d'ailleurs rencontré son
directeur qui nous explique le but du
festival c'est de favoriser dans la
vallée de la seine le le développement
du spectacle ayant pour les jeunes
publics et les familles notamment en
travaillant avec des lieux de petites
communes de
des endroits où le spectacle ne va pas
nécessairement beaucoup donc pouvoir
proposer aux enfants et à leurs familles
des spectacles de proximité d'une façon
pour éviter les grands déplacements il
ya beaucoup dans cette partie du
territoire il ya beaucoup de
communes rurales ou périurbaines jeu
n'ont pas réellement de programmation à
l'année donc c'est une façon d'être
présents sur le territoire pour pour
favoriser le spectacle jeune public pour
retrouver cet entretien complet rendez
vous dans le prochaine le prochain 7,8
culture présentée par célia 400 go
l'excellente coeliaque get on go live le
moment à présent bixente de votre invité
oui aujourd'hui nous recevons katrine
noël adjointe en charge de l'animation
de la culture et du patrimoine de la
commune de croissy sur seine bonjour
bonjour bonjour katrine noël vous êtes
avec nous parce que la ville de croissy
sur seine s'est associé à universcience
l'établissement regroupant le palais de
la découverte et la cité des sciences et
de l'industrie pour ces quatre
prochaines années et je crois savoir que
vous sortez tout juste de la
finalisation et de la signature du
contrat est-ce que cet acte est
exactement nous avons signé à 14h30 donc
la réception de cette exposition donc
cette exposition cabanes qui est comme
vous l'avez dit à un partenariat entre
la ville de croissy sur seine et
universcience qui regroupe en effet la
cité des sciences et de l'industrie et
le palais de la découverte justement
comme vous l'avez dit l'association
commence dès ce mois de février plus
précisément le 22 février avec
l'exposition cabane présente au château
chan auriez un voyage vers l'imaginaire
pour les enfants de 2 à 7 ans est ce que
pouvait vous pouvez nous en dire plus je
crois que vous vous trouvez justement
dans une de ces cabanes en ce moment
exactement je suis dans une de ces
cabanes et comme vous l'avez dit c'est
un voyage pour les enfants et c'est
surtout un voyage vers l'imaginaire en
fait chaque concept est assez différent
beaucoup sont à utiliser avec des
produits recyclés donc en plus on reste
dans l'air du temps il y a donc
plusieurs sortes de cabanes et
il y ana ya notamment un moment phare de
l'exposition qui s'appelle le grand défi
où c'est une énorme cabanes et les
enfants peuvent construire eux mêmes
avec du matériel du bois du tissu des
coussins etc leurs propres petits lieux
et voilà il ya aussi une cabane qui
regroupe des livres ou les enfants avec
leurs parents peuvent s'asseoir et puis
regardez non seulement des livres que
nous nous avons tous connu à notre
époque mais aussi des livres qu'ils vont
découvrir par eux-mêmes bref c'est un
moment d'évasion et vraiment on est très
fiers de pouvoir présenter cette
exposition l'exposition cabanes qui est
la première exposition du projet petit
curieux de la cité des sciences pour ces
prochaines années vous aurez toutes les
expositions qui proviennent de ce projet
petit curieux non mais alors là donc on
commence par cette exposition cabanes
qui est la première exposition hors les
murs en ile de france 2 pour le grand
public de la cité des sciences donc ça
c'est déjà extraordinaire et à partir du
mois de décembre
à peu près à la période de noël nous
aurons une exposition qui s'appelle
chiens et chats et qui fera aussi le
bonheur du grand public des enfants mais
aussi des adultes
donc donc voilà donc je pense que là
juste pour information la l'exposition
cabanes qui a eu lieu à la villette
avait attiré pratiquement 220 mille
visiteurs on n'espère pas en faire
autant ici mais on a beaucoup d'espoir
pour que au moins les vacances là soit
déjà plein et on a déjà beaucoup
d'inscriptions et pourquoi était ce
important pour la ville de croatie de
développer ce programme tous et rendez
vous pour les enfants de 2 à 7 ans
écoutez ça a toujours été la politique
de la ville de croatie de d'attirer les
enfants parce qu'on sait que quand on
travaille avec les enfants on rencontre
les parents et pratique c'est une ville
familiale où il ya énormément de petits
et donc de grandes donc on a toujours
travaillé comme ça et même avec les
expositions prévues précédente donc
voilà c'est un peu le concept de la
ville de s'adresser surtout aux enfants
et rapidement en deux mots pour les
vacances il ya aussi d'autres choses
prévues g crevant un stage de cirque par
exemple ah oui un stage de cirque il ya
énormément de médiation culturelle on a
une médiatrice culturelle qui qui fait
des expositions on a beaucoup de à
l'école de musique on a un stage on a
micro folie aussi où les enfants
pourront découvrir
lowe's et puis la bibliothèque qui fait
aussi pas mal d'animations il ya l'heure
du conte tous est à retrouver sur notre
site croit si.com et là vous aurez
toutes les informations concernant les
vacances et bien parfait je crois qu'on
s'est tous merci beaucoup katrine noël
d'avoir est avec nous et donc nous avons
été
nous avons être voilà de découvrir
l'exposition cabanes qui ouvrira ses
portes le 22 février prochain et
jusqu'au 30 mars au château chalon riait
de croissy sur seine le rendez vous est
pris merci effectivement à votre invité
à d'accord ok merci merci noël alors on
termine bixente avec des rendez vous
immanquable il y en a pendant ces
vacances d'hiver mais on commence à
thoiry il ne reste que quelques semaines
pour profiter des huiles il des
illuminations je vais arriver ferrique
proposé par le zoo de thoiry plus de
1500 animaux plantes et personnages à
venir voir jusqu'au 6 mars prochain deux
plages horaires possibles pour les lève
tôt l'éveil ferrique de 7h30 à 10 heures
pour les gens comme moi les lumières
sauvage de 17 heures à 20 heures pour
les tarifs vous pouvez accéder
uniquement au parcours d'illumination
qui fait environ 1 km 500 dans les
jardins du château mais aussi combiner
et prendre une formule avec le zoo
safari également à 30 euros il termine
avec une autre sortie en plus on peut se
cultiver à l'exception vous savez
grégory que j'aime bien toutes ces
sorties nature autour de la faune et la
flore est ce que vous connaissez la
gemmothérapie
non non c'est j'arrive dire vous avez
bien c'est tout récent ça provient du
latin gmail qui veut dire bourgeon c'est
une nouvelle médecine douce alternative
qui se base sur le pouvoir guérisseur
des bourgeons justement pour en
apprendre plus rendez vous le samedi 26
février prochain au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles une balade en
forêt d'une heure trente à partir de
14h30 pour apprendre à reconnaître les
arbres et leurs bourgeons en hiver infos
et réservations sur le site de
l'organisateur nature et vous point
wordpress.com merci et bixente pour
toutes ces idées de sorties et c'est
déjà la fin de ce set week-end mais on
prend rendez vous bien sûr la semaine
prochaine vendredi prochain merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis l'info locale qui
revient dès lundi en direct à 18h sur tv
78 et d'ici là passez un excellent
week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]